voilà pour cette intervention de jens
stoltenberg secrétaire général de l'otan
qui sans surprise bien sûr accuse la
russie et sa guerre illégale inhumaine
en ukraine je cite il a souligné aussi
le risque de catastrophe nucléaire
on va en parler avec deux personnes
présentes sur ce plateau guillaume la
scuderia ce bonjour vous êtes notre
consultant militaire historiens un
militaire et bruno daroux chroniqueur
internationale france 24 bruno je me
tourne vers vous en premier on a on a
l'impression d'un discours en deux temps
en quelque sorte de l'otan d'une part on
renforce les forces de dissuasion face à
la russie c'est ce qui a été dit on
renforce le soutien ou les pays membres
en force le soutien à l'armée
ukrainienne
mais d'un autre côté on ne veut pas
participer au conflit on le souligne
aussi c'est une sorte d' exercice
d'équilibriste oui enfin là il a pas dit
que l'otan allait soutenir l'armée
ukrainienne 1 ce sont des dpi et lei
mensuels qu'il veut pays membres de
l'otan soutient l'armée kényane a là ça
risque de dégénérer en fait il a redit
qu'il souhaitait que la solution passe
par la voie diplomatique mais qu'en
attendant lui dans dans son rôle en fait
je faisais en sorte que cette alliance
militaire défensive il l'a répété soit
en état d' alerte maximale
mais dans une posture des fossiles de
légitime défense le long de sa frontière
orientale dont il a rappelé tout ce qui
avait été fait ces derniers jours pour
renforcer la présence de l'otan que 6
des pays-bas lé de la pologne ou de la
route d'où la roumanie il a répété que
l'otan allait défendre chaque centimètre
carré de son territoire des choses qu'il
avait déjà dit mais l'important c'était
de montrer que l'otan était prêt à
réagir au cas où donc là le message
s'adresse évidemment au kremlin et par
ailleurs il a répété aussi et le message
est également adressée au kremlin mais
ce qu'on savait déjà il l'avait déjà dit
mais vu les circonstances il l'a répété
que l'otan n'allait pas intervenir
directement en ukraine y compris sur la
fameuse zone d'exclusion aérienne
justement guillaume la scuderia sur 7
sur cette zone d'exclusion aérienne
c'était une demande de kiev qui a été
rejeté de manière assez claire par
l'otan parce que trop dangereuse alors
faut revenir en fait à ce que c'est
qu'une zone d'exclusion aérienne une
zone d'exclusion aérienne c'est tout
simplement la possibilité d'engager des
forces aériennes des avions de chasse
des avions de surveillance
directement dans un espace aérien qui
est contesté avec le risque
potentiellement cette fois
d'escarmouches voir littéralement de
combats aériens ou et de destruction
d'appareils dans un camp ou dans un
autre le problème d'une no fly zone
c'est que vous rentrez donc dans ces cas
là dans un autre espace aérien en
l'occurrence ce serait celui de
l'ukraine et et là vous devenez
directement parties au conflit puisque
si vous devez imposer cette zone
d'exclusion aérienne vous allez donc
devoir faire face à de danger d'abord
les avions russes et puis ensuite les
défenses
antimissiles et anti aérienne russes
aussi et là ça rend les choses beaucoup
plus compliquées puisque vous devenez
parties au conflit et c'est typiquement
ce que ce qui était dit l'otan ne veut
pas c'est à dire qu'on ne veut pas
véritablement imposé ou mettre en place
cette zone d'exclusion aérienne parce
que cela de facto rendre et un conflit
entre forces aériennes de la russie et
des pays membres de l'otan
littéralement inévitable avec une
escalade bio me l'as cannes charia ce
parmi les choses qui ont été dites donc
il y à ce sort de renforcement du
partenariat avec la suède et la finlande
notamment un échange d'informations en
force et est ce que c est ce que c'est
significatif alors ça vient en fait
après une succession de d'événements que
l'on observé en fait depuis déjà des
années qui est le veut le viol de la
souveraineté de l'espace aérien de ces
deux pays par des avions par des avions
russes alors ça peut se faire soit dans
le cadre de de contournement elle se
fait par des bombardiers stratégiques
russes ça a été le cas il ya me semble
deux jours par des chasseurs russes qui
ont violé la souveraineté aérienne de la
suède c'est un message très fort qui
avait envoyé déjà par moscou en disant
voilà si vous avancez trop en direction
de l'otan n'oubliez pas que nous sommes
finalement aussi voisins mais en
revanche quand l'eau tandis que on se
rapproche et que l'on partage des
informations avec la suède et la
finlande ça veut donc dire que
finalement les préoccupations de
sécurité de ces deux pays scandinaves
sont aussi celles désormais des alliés
et qu' il ya toujours cette possibilité
de les faire accéder plus rapidement ce
qui en fait provoquerait une sorte de
d'escaladé horizontal et non pas
verticale c'est à dire que on changerait
un peu de portage et que en intégrant ou
du moins en ayant cette menace
portée au kremlin comme finalement comme
message directement adressé à moscou en
leur disant m'écouter voyez on peut
prendre un autre bord deux autres alliés
et ça fait changer le portage
stratégique notamment au nord de
l'europe et bien effectivement il ya
l'idée de de dire que nous renforçons
cette présence nous renforçons ces
partenariats nous renforcions c'est
évidemment la capacité à protéger la
totalité du flanc est de l'ordre bruno
daroux c'est à un vrai risque ça
l'internationalisation du conflit que ça
déborde par la sueur la fin l'année
assure déjà la régionalisation à voir la
nationalisation mais je pense que même
si d'un point de vue alors plus
diplomatique cette fois-ci l'otan aller
plus loin rapidement on va dire on verra
la suède et la finlande par exemple si
c'était effectif a causé deux pays
adhérer à l'otan ce serait interprétée
très vite par le kremlin comme une forme
de
d'agression ou de co belligérance et
donc ça ne ferait qu'empirer les choses
dont je ne suis pas persuadé on n'est
pas loin de tromper je suis pas persuadé
que ça se passe dans un avenir proche
mais le signal envoyé est entre les deux
c'est à dire que puis ça vient d'eux
aussi de ces pays là qui souhaitent
approfondir leur partenariat avec l'otan
pour que vladimir poutine entendent
aussi cette éventualité mais dans le
contexte actuel qui est donc explosif si
vous me passez l'expression
se serait pas une très bonne idée que
d'aller provoquer la dîmière poutine
simplement ça veut dire que si ça
continue s'il continue dans cette voie
un peu erratique le résultat à moyen et
long terme ça peut être encore une fois
non pas comme il le pense est une
division de l'affaiblissement de l'otan
mais au contraire un renforcement de
l'otan y compris dans cette partie
scandinaves qui était jusque là assez
prudente justement sur sur ce thème du
renforcement de l'otan se rappelle la
fameuse phrase d' emmanuel macron
il ya quelques temps l'état de mort
cérébrale est un état de fait
complètement terminée là l'otan est au
centre du jeu alors en fait c'est vrai
que en l'espace d'une semaine ont
remarqué quel point l'eau tant que tout
le monde critique et et qui était en
fait présent ou absent des débats parce
qu'on l'accusait d'être incapable de
répondre à cette adaptabilité aux crises
du 21e siècle et bien finalement l'otan
ressort plus renforcée que jamais avec
quand même une une interrogation c'est
toujours de facto cette capacité ensuite
derrière à s'élargir là c'est autour de
cette question de l'élargissement que la
crise finalement se déroule c'est
finalement le conflit peut être lue sous
le spectre de la russie contre l'otan et
la russie contre l'otan et les états
unis donc cette vision là elle et elle
est très très clairs et finalement ça
montre bien que la garantie de sécurité
ce qu'on appelle l' article 5 la défense
collective qui fonde la nature même de
l'otan n'en est que plus plus importante
pour les pays les pays baltes pour la
pologne pour la roumanie cette croyance
en la solidarité de entre la solidarité
pendant de l'article 5 et la solidarité
de l'alliance transatlantique est le
fait que les américains viendront et
défendront eux aussi chaque centimètre
carré du territoire européen et bien
voilà en fait ce qui garantit l'intérêt
et la force de cette alliance bruno
daroux est-ce qu'on est face à un
événement s'aguerrir en ukraine d'une
telle ampleur que qu'un nouvel ordre
mondial se dessine en quelque sorte est
ce que ça va être assez fort pour
marquer marquer une frontière comme lors
de la guerre froide il est peut-être un
peu tôt pour le dire mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que certaines lignes sont en train
de bouger 1
on peut donc déjà considéré que cette
crise a isolé la russie est-ce que c'est
durable ou pas avoir également selon la
durée du conflit a permis à l'union
européenne d'effectuer dans certains
domaines une forme de révolution
copernicienne notamment dans le domaine
de l'indépendance stratégique voire
l'indépendance énergétique mais là il
faut traduire ensuite les bonnes
intentions en actes ça il faudra
vraiment voir sa gourde et au cours des
mois mais dans un de manière conceptuel
et presque philosophique on va dire
l'union européenne en fait s'est
retrouvé au delà de ses dissensions
internes qui pour le coup ont été
surmontées et affirme désormais le fait
qu'en tout cas elles commencent à
considérer qu'elle doit être aussi une
puissance militaire et une puissance
énergétique indépendante et souveraine
et ça c'est quand même très nouveau et
puis à l'otan qui se voit également
renforcé en tant qu'alliance militaire
mais qui se voit un peu empêché on le
voit par le fonctionnement même de cette
alliance qui fait qu'elle ne peut pas
intervenir dans un pays qui ne fait pas
partie de l'otan et qu'elle est obligée
quand même il faut quand même le dire de
laisser l'ukraine seule face à
l'agression russe
merci bruno et l'or